well congratulations to you guys too
okay first things first where did you
get the f off mask
because i've been telling him for years
to [ __ ] off and he won't so he decided
to give me a mask instead it was a
brilliant moment what's that like the
moment before like when they open the
envelope the moment before
you hear succession what is that moment
like
it feels like they're going to say squid
game yeah
that's what it feels like
but now listen the gang's all here you
guys are here every people are so
obsessed we're missing matthew and snook
and they're a huge part and fisher too
forgot about that guy whatever i've been
asking everyone raise your hand here if
you know what's happening in season five
i mean season four i'm sorry season four
you're like where are you thinking six
you know what happened
oh you know what's happening well then
you get over here brian
so what's the party going to be like
tonight for you guys
jeremy jeremy's got to cover him yeah
okay jeremy what's happening don't tell
him where we're going come on jeremy
what's happening come on
it's entertainment tonight come on
barney's beanery that's amazing
there's a whole scene that's going to be
set in eastern mongolia
now the only problem now with the new
war is trying to get there for the the
filming but you know we'll probably end
up filming in
you know the cat scores
we're gonna go with that for season four